[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm link and i'm
red this week at the round table of dem
lighting we're going to be sharing our
recent family adventures that happened
to each of us over the thanksgiving
break uh-huh i went to disneyland i
didn't so i got some i got some fresh
observations because it's been a while
since i've been there my friend well
you've been at disneyland at least
three times more than i have that's my
daughter since the last time i went
she's a disney freak i haven't been to
disneyland in four years five years
probably how's your back
i could tell when you walked in that
there was something going on well
one of the things that we'll talk about
is we actually spent thanksgiving day
together
did you notice that my back was
pretty messed up on thanksgiving day i
just i didn't know it so
it was messed up the whole week you just
seemed so grateful and that's all i
noticed and it was starting to get
better
by thursday
and then
it yesterday we're recording this on a
monday
yesterday sunday after thanksgiving
i'm like i'm back
what i'm back and my back is back okay
no more pain do you know what triggered
it i think i do and then last night i'll
tell you what i think it triggered it it
was back the back pain was back yeah but
then last so i go to bed i'm like we got
a big week we're doing some things that
we can't talk about yet
um and i tend to whenever there's a when
can we talk about it damn it i the fact
that it frustrates you so much is i find
very interesting what because it's the
main thing on my mind yeah but i don't i
like keeping secrets i don't like not
talking about things that are on my mind
okay
uh
whenever we're doing is good whenever
we're getting ready to do something new
i've noticed a pattern that my back will
go out like oh we're getting around i'm
getting ready to travel and we're
getting ready to do this new thing so
i've developed this ability to associate
this stress or whatever like does
something in the back muscles
i don't know how it works tension but
what that has done for me is it has let
me not get too stressed out when it
happens so it's like okay this is
temporary this isn't like oh gonna be
around for months and months and months
like it used to be around for a long
time so you're stressed out which causes
it but you're not getting stressed out
about the problems because that would
make it even worse and that's what's
happened in the past because i'm usually
able to be like okay you do your
stretches it'll be a few days sometimes
it might just be a few hours you never
really know this one lasted all week and
then like i said yesterday a full week
later now the thing i did tie it to the
physical thing i tied it to
is a really intense bench pressing
session okay now this might sound crazy
to you
um
how does bench press so far yes how does
bench press bench pressing affects your
lower back
i i was doing like a
an especially
long session and it was like it was
really intense
and then
what's wrong with you i'm just really
showing interest go ahead but let me but
but see this is the troubling thing is i
never really know
because i can always almost always tie
it to either
something that i did physically or
something that's stressing me out
because i'm always doing things
physically that might hurt me and i'm
always doing things in the in life that
might stress me out so lifestyle man and
so i'm like how did because sunday night
after i did this bench pressing session
i'm like oh man i'm really oh this oh
this is a bad one this is a deep one i
call it ground zero when it goes back to
what i feel is like the original disc
injury oh god
and then i'm reading a book that i got
about back injuries
that's one of my past times and um does
that make it worse in the first like
three pages the guy talks about avoiding
bench press i'm like what
and then he explains
where the pressure comes from i'm like
well it must be the bench press but it
could be the fact that i'm a little
stressed out
long story short he suggested doing
push-ups instead of bench press okay
so
yesterday i'm better i haven't worked
out the whole week because my back so
i'm like i'm gonna do a hundred push-ups
that's a lot not in one
you know i do like 20 sets of five
okay no i do five sets of two works 20
sets of five would be moronic i do five
sets of twenty no it wouldn't i mean
sometimes you gotta start you gotta
start with
and uh after the and so i i did that and
um was fine
all day yesterday
last night while sleeping which is this
is so common
while sleeping at like 2 a.m i wake up
and i and i'm like
oh
it wasn't like i rolled over and it
started hurting it was just like i woke
up because it was hurting oh
and i was like oh no man i was like okay
well i'll try and i tried to find a
comfortable position to sleep couldn't
really did go back to sleep got up did
my like extra long
stretching routine with the lacrosse
ball and all that stuff that i do every
day okay took some advil
put some bengay on there
and uh i'll be
i'll be fine but i am glad i'm glad that
the thing that we're doing that's
stressing me out is not happening today
but happening tomorrow and it does not
involve bench press yeah and it's not
like a physical thing it's not like
you have to be like have a lot of
lateral emotion as long as i can walk
and look in fact i did that this morning
as i walked to the kitchen i was like
does it look like something's wrong with
me when i walk and she was like
only if you know what you're looking for
so when we talk about this thing that
we're gonna do that we finally get to
talk about and we tell you the thing
that you can look for you'll know which
one to look at to then make a decision
as to whether or not you could tell if
my back was hurt
but i'm going to be fine don't worry
about me
i'm in top physical form
mentally
but physically boy let me just look at
me man good gracious have you noticed
how i've been walking lately
you'll be all right just don't don't
don't add
the back panic it's nice to know that
you've got that in its place because why
i remember the back panic
when you would just like you would be
like is this it
am i coming to see you ethel or whatever
fred sanford used to say i'm not beyond
traveling down to panama and getting
some stem cells injected in my lower
back
just so you know that is still a top of
mind could that be on monetized on
youtube oh 100 percent it will be when
we do it okay you should get some too
it's not gonna hurt oh yeah i mean i'll
be there i'll get some yeah i'll get
some in the uh in the shoulder that's
why i don't bench press yeah actually
you know what you i'm going to get some
of my shoulders
it pops out and then it will
usually go right back in and you can
just get it intravenously as well you
can just do a full treatment and feel
like superman and you know what lily has
the same thing of course
to transition into my daughter's back
uh she
this is lily's first time back from
college
for our thanksgiving break so we're
looking forward to that the whole reason
that we plan to go to disneyland was
because she is obsessed with disney she
loves disneyland
i she you know she's really into marvel
and star wars and now that all that's
folded in
to the park experience there's a smart
move on that i do want to tell you about
the specifics of that um
so the and we so we went for two days
and the first
after we stayed in the hotel the first
night
um
we went to downtown disney then bedded
down for the night for our first day at
the park real fresh real early so we get
an absolute full day did you stay in the
park no you stayed like outside of the
parking just like a hotel i was meaning
like wait until it closes and like get
under something
no
there's an urban legend that lincoln was
telling me about that there's like that
mark twain island in the middle of uh
disneyland he said some people swam over
there and started all night that's true
and then tom sawyer island tom sawyer
and then they tried to swim back and
then a a
with a baby and the baby died or
something i didn't listen too closely
because like that was kind of a downer
early in the day but
just so you know i'm not recommending it
you could easily stay inside there
there's so many places to hide there's
so many places to hide now if you get
caught you're in a lot of trouble and
doing it the whole family doing it this
is a lot at stake family of five you
know what i'm gonna do i'm just gonna go
sleep in a bed and come back the next
day and just buy a second ticket finding
a comfortable spot would be difficult
but that next the
first morning
lily said
i rolled over my sleep and my shoulder
came out oh man and i was like did it go
right about her back because no they're
back stuff and i was like you know what
i've given you this this is this is the
genetic this is the physiology of how
your shoulders are built you're like me
sometimes i've rolled over in bed or
reached for something
i thought that i had damaged it in like
middle school when you started taking me
to that bench press behind the bathroom
at the law school that like your dad
gave us access to and we would go bench
press there and i would be pushing so
much weight and then like i would start
laughing and we would have had laugh
attacks while bench pressing you would
start laughing and the bar would be on
my chest and like you you couldn't get
it off of my chest because i was
laughing because you were laughing so
hard no and then sometimes my shoulder
would pop out and i thought that's what
did it but
let me stop you there i have developed a
theory and you are confirming it right
now and i've confirmed it multiple times
hey i'll confirm a theory if it's right
98
percent of the time
people
misassociate
whatever they're dealing with with the
cause okay so i can't tell you how many
times people say i got food poisoning
and then oh yeah yeah and they're like i
had i agree with that i was at the
applebee's last night and i got those
riplets and i've got food poisoning
right 98 of the time they're wrong
because food poisoning almost always is
associated with your last meal your most
recent meal when it almost is never
related to your most recent meals it's
kind of like me and farts and i you know
i thought
i'm always saying that i farted and
you're like that's not what you just ate
it's what you ate yesterday yeah but you
but you've literally gotten done with
lunch thrown it away come back in and
farted and been like sure those beans i
had for lunch i'm like dude those beans
you have for lunch are like sitting in
your stomach
nothing has happened in your colon yet
pushing gas through everything else no
that's not how it works
but anyway but food poisoning is sad
because then you're never eating those
riblets again and it's not the riblet's
fault yeah but the shoulders popping out
was not the bench press it's just
genetic look
you're right and that is what i'm saying
yeah yeah yeah i'm saying but you
forever associated it with bench press
just like i forever associate my back
problems with bad deadlifting in high
school yeah i thought that i had
stretched out my my shoulder stuff and
then for the rest of my life it was
popping out
for those just listening
who knows what i'm doing right now oh
gosh this is why you need to watch this
is why you shouldn't watch the video
version
he's giving you multiple reasons to not
watch the video version this week
so uh like father like daughter her
shoulder's popping out too buddy but
she's not experiencing back issues i'm
not no i'm just fighting again she's not
related to you no but link
she has a bionic spine i'm just
interested it's like yeah ain't nothing
wrong with that it's a it's bionic i
know i'm just but like she's not having
any pain with that that's great um
sometimes a little bit okay well there
thanks i didn't know that's what you
were talking about i just yeah i just
didn't you don't have a bionic spine but
i might need one
uh it's quite a recovery for a
middle-aged man yeah i don't i'm not
signing up for that
i don't yeah i don't want fusion surgery
unless i absolutely have to have it
let's do some ads for ourselves okay
mythical.com
if you want to get
this amazing color changing mug
when you put in hot stuff it reveals a
design and you see it on the desk a good
myth of good morning this entire past
season well it's going away it's going
away
that's right
if you want this mug you have to get it
by the end of the year because it's
going away and it's very special if you
want to get this world's best boss mug
uh i'm assuming you just go to amazon
and search it because i just picked it
out of the cabinet in there i mean it's
a shitty mug
i mean it's it's literally like i mean
look at this time to go to amazon.com
mythicalfirst we'll go to amazon.com
make sure we don't sell it if we don't
then you could probably there's multiple
places where you nobody has rights to
this
this is stupid mythical.com amazon.com
mythical but again for our mug
mythical.com
get it while you can because it will be
gone uh well just to get the physical
stuff out of the way
a couple of weeks
ago everyone in your family got sick one
by one
right is that how it started it went
through your whole family i felt sure it
went we got it from someone in your
house
it was a cold
and i don't know if you got it from
somebody in my house i thought we did
well all right because we were asking
how long how long did shepherd have it
shepard's always got something man he's
always got something get you something
while playing video games i think is
what's happening and then
he's getting the bugs from the video
games then orlando got it then lincoln
got it one by one it went through your
whole family then i got it
then christy got it okay and so
and that was a couple weeks ago
so
leading into thanksgiving
on
the weekend before thanksgiving
like the monday
lock
is become sick
with a cold yeah
and
he has a fever
and we're like oh no man this isn't good
what could we do you know we did the
test it's not cove but it's just there's
so many viruses going around everybody's
getting colds right
and so
he felt like
crap for a couple of days
and then
went and jesse is like sending out
jesse's you know we we've got a crowd
that's pretty
tense when it comes to sickness in
general yeah the people that we were
having over for thanksgiving
and so uh jesse was like i want to let
y'all know that locke is sick he had a
fever but he's doing a little bit better
today and everybody was like we want to
come to thanksgiving
we we don't want to change plans we
don't want to have like a food exchange
we're going for it just let us know how
he feels in the morning then wednesday
as lock's getting better shepard starts
getting sick
shepard gets a fever like 101 or
something like that 102 maybe at one
point
still i don't know what the discussion
was at your house but jesse told
everybody and
everybody was like we're still coming
shepard will just wear a mask which he
did yeah and we ate outside which we
were planning on eating outside anyway
it's california baby that's why you
moved to california so you can eat
outside next to the pool on thanksgiving
eat it
god okay
i love it here meaning the food eat the
food keep moving to austin i love it
here um
so
we had that and then
friday
jesse
starts coming down with it and i'm like
oh no no i'm
i'm holding out i'm lo i don't even
understand how these viruses work i'm
like i bet bench pressing will keep it
in yeah i get i got expo surely i got
exposed to this at some point like
what's the incubation period are we hey
how's and so i'm first of all i'm doing
everything i can to not get sick
for the thing that we're going to be
doing this week because i
i i would take hurt back over a cold
yeah while doing the kind of thing that
we're going to be doing any day
so
i'm like man i can't get sick i can't
get sick so i'm like not i'm kind of
staying away from everybody for the most
part i'm like
taking all kinds of stuff that may or
may not work i'm staying very hydrated
i'm sleeping at least eight hours every
single night
i've done and so i feel like maybe i'm
in the clear jessie is she's almost all
the way through it they're all coughing
like crazy oh gosh they're just coughing
everywhere meanwhile yeah uh you know
lando was diligent wearing his mask
except when he was taking bites of food
and stink keeping his distance from
shepherd except when they were playing
the video games after we were done
eating
today
he is home from school with a fever
thanks to
thanks to your family but but hey the
food made it worth it hey but this is
the interesting thing
because i thought that the virus
that went through your family which now
you're making me think that it came from
my family to begin with
was the same virus that then got back to
us but it's a different virus because it
came back and now it's on lando again
yeah why would everyone get the same
thing twice
within weeks of each other i think so
now you're susceptible to the new one i
think i've been exposed and i made it
out
but you're susceptible yeah so you need
to be on top of everything hydration
sleep i'm in a tough spot just stay away
from your family it's surprisingly easy
i learned
[Laughter]
where do you you stay in the garage
bench pressing that's just constant
bench pressing i mean it definitely
knowing what everyone was bringing to
thanksgiving to
eat was a big factor in
in us saying hey we gotta find a way to
make this work i'm not gonna
we're not gonna not have thanksgiving
well but we would and then we would we
could have had it at our house there
wasn't gonna be an exchange of food
though oh really just like last year
last year it was just us
but mclaughlin's in the in the meals at
our house yeah but we took we exchanged
food with the mccarts oh
yeah
because they were on a strict lockdown
at that time
but but there was a food exchange there
was talk of a food exchange i didn't
want to do it and of course i was
i was the turkey man
this first of all the sides were
incredible and and i
kid you not
i
up until actually right now i mean i had
a smoothie for breakfast this morning
but
every single day since thursday
the only food i put into my body is
stuff from thanksgiving for breakfast
lunch and dinner nothing else i've only
eaten leftovers thursday
so i eat leftovers friday saturday and
sunday exclusively what you know
you're speaking of breakfast yeah
because i would because you wake up
later i need a brunch i'm i'm not eating
right when i wake up
i'm eating like midday okay and so i
just had two meals i just had like a
midday turkey and dressing brush
we ran out it's the advantage of having
it at your house you you ended up having
you had to have had more
yeah but that's the that's what you get
for having to you have to clean up
everything yeah but you get more william
brought the mac and cheese and that mac
and cheese was so good and there was so
much of it
i had mac and cheese last night i mean
and i texted him about it and i was like
man this is the gift that keeps on
giving it's good for the immune system
too so actually
i thought i thought about that and i
think that
on the whole
i think the food i was eating was better
than other choices i could have been
making i mean turkey's good for you
there was some collards in there those
sweet potatoes there's a lot of sugar
but there's also a sweet potato that's
good for you there's some collards
there's broccoli casserole which is
still broccoli casserole it has broccoli
and it went real fast
actually i was done with that on friday
we had that for three days i was able to
cause i took it back i took most of it
back but man it was so it was so good
when you've got this christie's special
nothing against you know i already said
how much i love california
i love california but if you're from
california
or you've been here too long
you've forgotten how to do thanksgiving
i'm sorry y'all you just
thanksgiving is not about being healthy
it's about the food tasting good i'm not
gonna tell the story again about the
super california thanksgiving we went to
that one time where they did
deconstructed stuffing which made me
wanted to physically hurt the guy who
served it to me
we had two types of stuffing oh wow they
were both great one of them had meats in
it well the sausages in the stuffing the
ones that jessie made is based on the
dressing her mom's her mom's recipe and
it's got hot and sweet like hot and
maple sausage built into it
and it's big and then the one that jenny
made uh is the classic one that like my
mama makes which i actually prefer the
classic one but i ate the hell out of
both of them
and so anyway i'm sorry again i love
california but it ruins your ability to
do thanksgiving correctly you need to be
from the south and possibly the midwest
and to get this correct um this is the
worst time to be giving this feedback
it's like we need to be giving this
feedback just right after having to play
this
but let me just talk quickly about the
turkey mishap that i had because uh
i didn't discern one and i ate the
turkey i embarrassed myself in front of
my neighbors oh
at least i'm thinking i probably did
i'm a turkey guy uh and i don't mean
that by like saying i really love turkey
i'm saying that i'm the guy who makes
the turkey for thanksgiving
turkey's okay yeah um i try to make it
as good as it possibly can be for the
holiday
i smoked one turkey and i don't mean
like i rolled it up in a joint
um
i i put it on a grill yeah i guess that
is what some people might think at first
but i don't think that's why it's
california i feel like
you know california thanksgiving you're
smoking turkey it's like what do you
mean by that is there a pipe involved
this means putting it on a grill
a smoker is smoking it for an extended
period of time
i did a whiskey maple glaze on this
thing i took the entire breast bone of
the turkey out
which is
the turkey put it really flat so it
cooks evenly
it was great
actually i made a little mistake with it
cooked faster than i wanted to i didn't
get to crisp the skin as much as i
wanted to but set that aside i also deep
fried two turkey breasts okay
uh jenny who loves white meat
uh our friend jenny she she brought
these two turkey breasts and she likes a
fried turkey so i was like yeah i'll do
it i don't watch like electric fryer it
makes it super easy
so i pull this thing out i've got the
turkey the smoking turkey is smoking
it's kind of doing its thing and i'm
like okay i'm ready to deep fry these
turkeys
i've got this electric
smoker that's like a big cube and i had
three gallons of peanut oil that i was
going to use as my oil you said smoker
but you meant fryer fryer sorry yeah
it's a big it's a fryer electric fryer
so it's not one of the ones where you
put it over the open flame and
potentially burn your house down
um
which i think i might have to upgrade to
that based on the story i'm about to
tell you though
so
i'm like okay i'm gonna fill this thing
up with oil
and
turn it on
so
as i'm getting ready to turn the to pour
the oil the three gallons of oil into
the fryer i think to myself
i remember there being like a valve at
the bottom of this thing
last year it's like a valve that you can
open to drain the oil when you're
cleaning it i'm like but it's underneath
this the
mechanism that's on the outside that has
the element heating element so i was
like
surely i didn't
not close that valve
what an idiot
and so i just pour it in there and then
i
i see that it's the level is three
gallons i'm like see i told you i closed
that valve i turned around to do
something to like
mess with the other turkey
and i turn back around and there is a
pool of peanut oil spilling out all
around the fryer all on top of my
outdoor bar area look look look
down onto the concrete and going into
the drain
straight oil hey good you got a drain
straight to the ocean
um
so
i panic
i pick up the heating element which is
attached to the control mechanism
and i set the whole thing inside the oil
i didn't even remember doing this until
later when i looked
and then i turned the valve and i screw
it up
and then so you were able to find the
valve pretty quickly when you needed to
yeah but there was a lot of oil that had
already left
and that was when i
now
i have neighbors
i have neighbors all around right this
is this is the do you have security cam
footage of this scramble i don't have no
no i don't i don't have a i don't have
an angle on that part i have an angle on
the entrance i didn't think you'd had an
angle on where you you cook you kind of
know where my neighbors are like we
share like the the yards are all kind of
together but they would have to all look
down they would look down on you oh it's
not about them seeing me it's about them
hearing me say oh
oh just once no i said it a couple of
times
i said it one time there and then i went
inside
told jesse i was like i made a big
mistake
and give me some paper towels and i was
like do you do yeah do you have oil i
said do you have
towels bath towels that we don't need um
yeah and she was like yeah these two two
she had two that had like yellow stains
on them so it's
so i'm like okay i go outside and i like
start cleaning it up and then i look and
i realize that that's when i realized
that the whole heating element with the
control mechanism okay is in the oil
even the even the electronics like the
dial
the electronic part of it
i pick it up oh you do you're having it
louder this time i'm sorry
and i was so mad like i get so mad at
myself when i make mistakes it's like
it's not healthy i'm in therapy is there
any other word i mean that's you were
you you were at you were over the edge
yeah and that was because i held it up
and saw the oil pouring out of the
inside of the housing this is this is a
fire hazard at this point and so then
i'm like i can't fry these turkeys
because what are you gonna do plug in
this fryer that's got oil inside the
electronics no well that's what i did
and it worked fine
well i let it drain for a really long
time
and then i was like you have to get oil
very very hot like think about the way a
heating element works it's inside this
thing and it's designed to heat the oil
up to like 400 degrees yeah the inside
of the heat the worst thing that could
happen is the electric
current which is what's happening in the
heating element to hook it up
it's just gonna it's not gonna catch it
on fire it's just gonna make it hot
inside the thing and it'll probably
smoke and maybe melt some of the plastic
but i'll be able to tell
at least that was my theory and i
completely drained it completely wiped
it down
turned it on and watched it for 10
minutes before i proceeded and it was
fine did you have the fire extinguisher
ready i brought the fire extinguisher
out did you read it say is this an
electrical fire one or a grease fire one
or oh both i i looked at it and i
couldn't come to conclusions about that
just
you know i just know i wasn't supposed
to put water on it but can you the thing
i feel about fire extinguishers is this
if you got one that's that is a victory
and just use it and see what happens
and you could say that you did your best
i don't i we need to look that up
because yeah is it is it bad to put a
fire extinguisher of any kind on a
grease fire or i know you can't put
water on it but hashtag your biscuits
but i will say that
a couple of the families that live
around us i believe are grandparents
because during the holidays you'll hear
children and during other times you
don't hear the children it's either
their normal family that only lets kids
outside during holidays
which is possible or it's grandparents
who are only having kids over so they
learned a word and so i think that yeah
they were like they're
that man down there is having something
something's wrong with him
oh hey but it turns out grease stain on
your uh on your concrete is that that's
that's tough no you know what i did i've
had some oil mishaps on this surface
already okay so what i did is i took one
of those bath towels and i polished the
entire surface with the peanut oil oh
and it just even it out
like it never happened that but it
smells good out there it does it smells
great just don't just don't smoke a
cigarette out there
you want to talk about disneyland yeah
um yeah so the first day we went to uh
i always want to call it islands of
adventure
but that's the um that's the universal
thing and it because that's what's in my
head i can't call it the right thing
where
when mythical was smaller we all went to
where's the car where's the car what's
the car's place
what's it called adventure
california adventure california
adventure yeah that's what it's called
yeah uh we went there on the first day
and then we went to disneyland proper on
on the second day i had not been to uh
islands of adventure
since
california adventure
i haven't been to the adventure yeah uh
since they
um
made uh avengers campus a thing there's
where is that uh you go in and you hang
a left is it was it something else it
was something else that wasn't memorable
and it and it didn't replace indiana
jones right anyway
that's in disneyland so tower of terror
is has been
revamped as a guardians of the galaxy
ride oh the ants the ant world ant world
that's that's gone ant's ride is gone
that that was a bit that was a big area
that had like a you could walk through
like their kids stuff yeah and you
seemed like you you it was like never
yeah yeah the kids don't know it was
time for that to go right see we never
went there they changed that into
avengers campus and then the the pier
part with like the roller coaster yeah
and the big ferris wheel and like the
the water and the corn dog castles and
the corn dog castle that you love
they're not getting rid of that corndog
castle is still there they're never
getting rid of that um pinnacle of the
park i almost got one but i didn't
they changed that because that's pixar
pier
and then there's like um
those rides so cars land kind of got
extended out into the cars land as well
the cars land
but pixar
but i was
i was most i mean we went to california
adventure and they made that
uh roller coaster into
an incredible themed roller coaster but
it's the same roller coaster
and christy was very proud of herself
because she went on that but she didn't
tell us how petrified she was that she
was overcoming something the wooden
roller coaster yeah not a huge fan of it
but it but it was fine um but the
avengers campus there's this brand new
spider-man ride that like i don't know
if you if you if you know on pixar pier
there's a
um
like a
a vr ride where you're playing all these
carnival games with 3d glasses on
and it's like pixar
toy story themed stuff and that's really
awesome that's been there a while you're
shooting you're shooting rings and stuff
oh that's keeping a score yeah that's
amazing
um well they did a spiderman ride
that is basically the same approach but
instead of like using a cannon that
you're actually
pulling on something physical and then
these imaginary 3d rings are coming out
you just
throw out your hand as if you're uh
casting a web like your spider-man
you don't have to make the noises but i
did
um and it just does you feel like it's
accurate it's pretty accurate and you
you're you're throwing them and so
you're on this track and you're zinging
around and there's all these there's
this set design but then all these
screens and it's 3d glasses and all that
we waited for like an hour and a half to
get on that ride
because it's not worth more than an hour
they've done away with the fast pass
that's gone which i do do you having
been there now
if you're
okay why did they get rid of the fast
pass it was just becoming clogged i
didn't i didn't research why is it like
a traffic issue with everybody going to
the fast pace who knows all of their
reasons but if you if you have an annual
pass you can then get something which
will give you an
um a comparable experience to fast pass
i think but because i couldn't get that
we don't have annual passes
we just waited in line but that's way
too long for spider-man especially when
i halfway through the ride i was so
exhausted and i was pretty shoulder
popped out i thought my shoulder was
going to pop out both of them like i'd
come out of the thing that's limp armed
yeah just the rest of the day knuckle
dragging
you got to be careful when you when you
got that neophysiology right can't be
spider-man but the the tower of terror
turned into the guardians of the galaxy
ride was amazing i would have waited 90
minutes for that still works in the same
fashion yes the same mechanically it's
just you get on
basically an elevator and then the doors
open
the elevator's falling and rising and
the doors are opening at different
levels and you're seeing
um
different video screens but the way that
they themed it
you know the
in guardians and in some of the other
marvel movies like benicio del toro
played the collector
and so
they turned the whole thing into the
collector's museum so when you're going
through the line
it there's like all these specimens
plant specimens
um
weaponry all of this stuff from the
marvel cinematic universe that he's
collected to kind of make the the line
yeah
and that that was cool and then you get
in there and it's he's got he's captured
the guardians
and then they're each on display so you
got to get him out by getting on an
elevator this is the main opening there
well you're the the premise is you're
just there
attending the opening of his new exhibit
which is seeing the guardians so like
it's really cool when everything in the
line and everything leading up to it
does that but then when you get in there
yeah like
rocket escapes is it the real actors
doing all of it yeah as far as i can
tell it sounds like it i think they've
oh well yeah definitely i mean
definitely there's footage there's
footage of all of them
that's like for the ride at this point
that's got to be in the contract uh yeah
i'm thinking because you know back in
the day they didn't do it you'd show up
at the ride i'm doing a ride it's like
that's not that's not christopher reeve
right or whatever it was you know it's
definitely what's his name from parks
and rec yep chris pratt yeah him you
couldn't remember chris pratt's name you
know he's definitely uh he's definitely
in it and zoe saldana
i'll remember her name any day of the
week yeah right and if you give me your
phone number i'll remember that too i
doubt that no i wouldn't
uh i don't remember phone numbers
anymore you just store them in your
phone yeah that was all a joke anyway
uh
anyway if you had if you had to the
theme if you had to meet her would you
rather her be painted she is or green oh
green that would be awesome
and then i know she really worked for it
to meet me it's like oh you put in hours
just because i said i wanted to meet
them i was on the jet bridge the green
version
her man one time i remember that you
told me about it
um that ride was thrilling again it's
the same ride physically but i've never
experienced the
theme being placed on a ride and it
making it so much more satisfying yeah
and you know there's a lot of purists
who get upset about that kind of thing
who are like toe roof
been completely compromised because
they've made it the avengers ride i
don't see how anyone could complain
because there's so much more people can
complain and it's so
i mean it can be complained about it
will be my second favorite ride
and then towards the end of the day
we time to go in the cars line which
was over an hour that's a good ride but
when the sun's setting on a good time
the set design of that world is just it
holds up so many years later and it
doesn't even matter if you've it's like
it's a real desert if you've seen the
movie it's so beautiful yeah and then
you get on the ride and you're like
you're in the car and like your
joyriding through this and you're just
looking around like
like i'm i'm in monument valley it never
gets old i i i love that it's so great
so that's my my third favorite ride but
on the second day we went to disneyland
hold on so you didn't go you didn't go
on soaring we did go on swimming
i love soaring sauron takes you around
the world i love it man it's not just
california beyond california it takes
you around the world
and you smell things and you smell stuff
what kind of stuff you smell now oh man
i got to go back grass you smell grass
because they when they went over the
orange fields yeah you don't store them
oh the citrus citrus you're wearing a
mask now you got to wear a mask inside
with all this pandemic stuff have you
heard about it
so you're wearing them when something's
going around
and
you were what you wearing
the whole time you're in disney but just
when you go inside just inside
just is a roller coaster considered
inside
uh space mountains inside a mountain no
i think you're moving too fast for the
virus at that point they can't keep up
with the roller coaster well space
mountain i didn't ride that so i don't
know if they made you wear the mask
because that is indoors you probably did
have to wear the mask but i won't know
the second day
i was like as long as i can ride the
rise of the resistance which i have
never ridden
i have been to uh galaxy's edge like the
star wars world i thought you had you
wrote that the first time you went no
just the millennium falcon ride
but rise the resistance but it wasn't
done lily had been on it but no it was
they weren't even talking about it the
last time i went
and of course this this ride is built up
so much to the point where i'm like
okay i know that it says that it's a
two-hour wait
for this ride but
this is the best
ride
theme ride on the planet potentially
from from everything i've heard
so i'm
i'm not going to wig out about it i'm
just going to get in line
and
first of all talk about the lines and
the walking like you're not ready for
this i was i was not ready you need a
pair of wheelies for being on my feet
all by the about halfway through the
afternoon of the first day
i had to sit down and i was eating a
taco and then i was like y'all just hey
y'all just go and do some stuff i'm
gonna sit here and i went to sleep
christie sent a picture of you uh to our
group chat and you were just sleeping
you were like sitting up there you were
no there was one where you were lying
down yeah i ended up lying down
it was like well first i took my my i
took my shoes and my socks off
and she was like this is a restaurant
and i was like this isn't a restaurant
this is just some tables
everyone did what you did what if
everyone took their shoes and socks off
at disney
i saw a few other people doing it so
it's not like something i invented okay
let me tell you i was in a corner on my
right was nothing but plants there were
there was talk about escorting you out
just so you know between like
herb from omaha nebraska and dale from
you know st louis missouri because it
says it on their name tag they were like
we got a we have a barefoot we have a
barefoot situation what i mean people
walking around his sandals give him
another seven minutes
people kick off their sandals
i just kicked off my shoes and my socks
yes
and i needed to kicking off socks is
never good man for everybody else
i'm sure it was good i feel bad but i
was desperate and then i was like i just
have day one i just day one i was
hurting man and i was just late i was
just sitting there and then it was a
chair and then once once they got up and
left
then i moved over two more chairs and
then i just laid down
and literally went to sleep for at least
20 minutes and boy i needed every second
of that this makes me think about
there's a couple of potential
modifications that they can make to the
line now obviously they're doing a lot
to make
the line more entertaining because
they're like you know making it like his
museum or whatever
so there's interest factor along the way
but that only goes so far two ideas
number one is provide a way for people
to just lie down and slowly be
pushed take your shoes and socks off and
just slowly be pushed some people are in
those motorized carts but why can't
everyone but just something yeah i mean
something for everyone that doesn't take
up too much room
second potential option and i know
there's people who take this into their
own hands
and they come up with like a game to
play while they're in line
i kind of feel like yeah the heads a lot
of people are playing the heads up game
but like maybe disney could actually
create
line games lying games
and that's a good idea and they bring
them to you i know an imagineer who
works in the parks i i mean i could make
a phone call
and i could suggest this and then maybe
get
10 i saw the people doing heads up and
then i just felt like
now that if i did that it wouldn't be an
original idea as a family we never even
talked about but if you're like you're
in the star wars ride
line this is the game that you can play
in the line and it's just like
you know it's the line is suited to it
sometimes
i did notice the one thing that
they did even when the line was like 90
minutes
and that's really what rise of
resistance was once we got in it now i
will say it ended up only being an hour
so
it moved faster
the thing i noticed was that was
manipulation yeah they
they raise the bar and then they make
you happy yeah
low expectations man
the line
never stopped moving it wasn't stop and
start stop and start
and there were even some benches placed
along the way but because the line never
stopped you couldn't sit on a bench so i
found that interesting but it did help a
lot psychologically but what it didn't
help with was like by day two
when it was my nap time again here i am
in this line and i can't even sit down
for a second
so
and i'm i'm just my hip flexor
is just hurting you're talking first of
all you started off this episode talking
about your physical
your physical form
or your physical peak or whatever yeah
that was a setup this is the payoff okay
got it um
and so i just the only thing that would
give me relief
was deep squats like if i really
squatted down it would my hips would
would open up a little bit and i'd start
to feel better
but the line wouldn't stop so i had to
and i didn't want to just keep squatting
down and squatting up
so when i squatted down and i moved then
i just started duck walking
behind the you know in the line and
i experienced lots of relief and
ridicule from my family i didn't realize
it that christy was posting this on her
instagram story
aft like i didn't realize until the next
day that like my duck walk and my
napping session were posted on
here's the thing link you are free to
make all these choices
but others are free to ridicule you for
them i mean that's that's what america
is all about man desperate man i was i
was i would have i would have stripped
down naked and done like the
the anus drag dog drag
if if if that was anyone else suffering
in this way i wasn't i'm not saying that
my anus was itching i'm saying if it was
to the point that i was hurting in other
ways that's what i would have done did
you get uh okay yeah recognize was
anybody else
um well i'll answer that in a second but
the question i thought you were going to
ask was anybody else doing anything with
ridicule yes i'm not alone there was a
guy in front of me in the line and he
had a full-size ziploc bag
with a rotisserie chicken okay that's
worse and he would open the ziploc bag
and he didn't buy the rotisserie chicken
at the park and that's not being sold
well first of all that's illegal you
can't bring in chicken christy ended up
talking to him and he said that his
grandma made a chicken and then since
they were coming to the park he said
well i'm not i'm not going to give up
grandma's chicken and so he brought it
in this zipline has he heard of
refrigeration
and then he opens the ziploc bag and
then he just starts eating he doesn't
wet chicken he doesn't yes he doesn't
touch the chicken with his hands he just
eats out of the gap in the ziploc bag
eating around the bones and then he'll
he would open it up and offer it to his
older sister she's like 17 years old oh
how old was he
like 15. okay so
he was offering his gapped ziploc bag
with rotisserie chicken bag to his
sister who was doing the same thing it
was like feeding a horse yeah
it's like feeding the freaking runs in
the family you should be happy that
chicken bag was close to you because it
was a great cover because yeah cause
he's like squat squat
duck walker squat walking man maybe a
superhero dude right there
put us in the collection get away with
anything of chicken bags around uh rise
of resistance was a 20 minute experience
which is pretty crazy
and
it
start i mean it's this entire story that
i kind of don't want to tell all of it
because i don't want to spoil it for
people is it not a story that exists
somewhere in an existing piece of ip no
it's um
it's a particular time when like
general hux
you know the guy from ex machina who's
not oscar isaac the red-haired guy yeah
um
and then kylo ren are are like uh
they're the main characters
and
you're
you're on this resistance transport that
gets hijacked that well that gets
intercepted by them and taken into their
ship you know that was tough for adam
driver to do well you never saw adam
driver's face you just saw the mask and
i don't i don't know if it was it wasn't
it dude adam driver he first of all he
had to swallow a lot of pride just to
get be a part of the star wars franchise
but when they said the ride thing he was
like as long as i don't have to do the
rides oscar isaac was was oscar will do
anything for a paycheck
he's great
daisy ridley was in it uh
uh shoot the guy who played uh
anybody who shows their face yeah
and um
so we're on the
so it's this whole story of like you're
in you get in a transport but then it
gets it gets uh tractor beamed or that's
star trek but it gets tractor beamed
into
uh
the kylo ren's ship and then you're
inside of the ship and you get off you
get off of the thing you were in like
the simulator and then you're walking in
this the expanse of this thing is this
huge you're in this huge
like there's a whole freaking
hanger
full of ships and storm troopers and
they're like all right move this way to
be interrogated and then you're
interacting with actual so it's like
you're entering into the world
which is the whole point of completely
immersive and so you get strapped into
something you're in a vr environment you
you get well you know the guy strap
you're walking around i could walk
anywhere i could have i could have ran
through a bunch of star troopers star
troopers storm troopers and just like
gone nuts well so on this place the the
guy that i was not restrained you you
got a duck walk all over it you know the
guy that i'm talking about you don't he
he's he's friends with
our family knows him but you've met him
but he would he told me all about no he
didn't tell me like details but
basically when he talked about star wars
like
four years ago yeah he would he would be
like it's going to be crazy it's going
to be like you're walking into the movie
and
and i was like gosh
i was like
yeah that's what you get what do they
think but they're going to like keep you
like restricted and stuff but you're
saying that you can they you got off of
a ride you were walking around a hangar
being ushered into another place what if
you did what if you went crazy what if
you did start running they shoot you
yeah i think i mean there's lots of
weaponry lots you get zapped
and they probably just
they were probably ready to make it part
of the thing they wouldn't take their
because like no one with a name track
would show up they would just storm
troopers would take care of well you
were a prisoner being interrogated at
one point we were put into a cell
and then you know kylo ren comes in and
he's g and he's like he's about to let
us have it but then he gets called into
other businesses and we get rescued from
that but when kylo ren is a dude in a
costume uh it was a screen at that point
and then at other points it was
animatronic versions of him and hux so
that it was very mixed media everything
that
disney has ever done in the theme ride
at different points you experienced all
of it and more
super impressive like i i can't remember
the last time
that like i've just
walked around with my mouth gaped open
for like any for eight minutes straight
you shouldn't do it do that during the
pandemic just i have a mask on no one
could tell like underneath my mask i was
just gaped open the whole time like that
ziploc bag with the rotisserie chicken
yeah what was chicken back with you
chicken bag uh got interrogated in
another did they take his chicken back
they should have taken him out for that
i think he was zapped but i think they
would have i mean if you if you'd cross
some lines they probably would have kept
it part of the
you know i think i think there's a
threshold at which point
there's like a there's a level one
there's like a level one we can keep the
narrative going there's a level two okay
level three is when the narrative breaks
down and like actual
kurt from missouri comes in
and takes you out right you know
uh
i i
i was so amazed i didn't want to i
didn't want to push the boundaries of
anything or you could i wanted to
experience it as it was meant to be you
couldn't move fast enough but was that
right cause any problems um
you know i had this mindset that like
you know what
this is i'm gonna let lily be in charge
she's been in she's been at all these
disneylands
i'm not gonna be in charge of okay we
need to get up at this time we need to
get here we need to go here we need to
get in line this way we need to minimize
how long we're in line and we need to
eat at this time and
you know i really tried to totally
relinquish control
empower her and and be done with it and
and i think the report on that is
pretty good you know i did good i have
some notes but i'm pretty good um
she's a lot like me so she had a lot of
opinions so it i think that made it
where we didn't fight
nobody really fought because everybody
was like okay this is this is lily's and
you got to see everything that you
wanted to see you were two days is
really what you need i guess at this
point with all that stuff and all the
waiting yeah uh we still saw everything
we wanted to see but i didn't get
recognized as much as lily got
approached like on day one
she she like cosplayed as um
uh
loki and going into the like the
avengers all the avengers stuff so like
she had been loki for halloween and then
she did a version of that so like all
these people some other people who are
like
fans of loki or dressed up like loki as
well like she made friends with a couple
of girls that were all dressed up like
loki
so people were coming up to her wait
where did you get your where did you get
your your low-key ears and what or
whatever and then the next day we went
to star wars so she was your proverbial
chicken bag she was yeah and when it
comes to when it comes to getting
recognized right you're gonna have
something she was ahsoka the next day
she like made her own ahsoka tano uh
what is that uh
this female character from the star wars
universe and she's gonna ha she was in
most recently in the
uh the mandalorian she showed up
towards the end oh yeah okay and she's
gonna have her own show
and uh if i showed her to her
you you know you'd recognize her yeah um
rosario dawson yeah plays her uh now
she made her own ears and she and um
people were coming up to her the second
day and and
more than came up to me but when people
came up to me of course they all called
me rhett yeah which happened keep it
that way
uh i've been called link many times but
what really though
yeah okay
makes me feel better i've been called
link by people who i'd been with for
hours
i think that if you're just meeting
you're probably going to say the word
rhett versus the word link to associate
both of us when you don't really know
who's who
but that's what at least what i tell
myself but the thing that never happens
that did happen was i was seated
somewhere and somebody came up to me and
the first thing i saw was somebody put a
phone in my face and it was a picture of
us
and then i looked up and the guy said
this wouldn't happen to be you would it
oh that's an interesting tactic i was
like uh
yeah i'm the one on the right
this and i'm like making a face like
this is super strange
people people don't they don't always
have a plan yeah that well i mean that's
kind of the thing you have to plan out a
little bit i'm going to google and i'm
going to i guess he had confirmation but
then he wanted me to confirm it which i
did it was just strange i have a quick i
have a quick uh holiday uh recognition
story now that you've told that one that
i just remembered i had to do a little
uh shipping
and so i had to do you know some like
some boxing and some like tracking
shipping
um shipping that needed to be tracked
and um
so i go to the local
this is i guess it's the ups store
and of course i mean around the holidays
i mean bonanza it's like
there's seven people in line when i get
there and i'm like oh gosh and
everybody's got a different request and
the guys working there are you know
teens
uh and nothing i mean i'm standing in
lines for for an hour and a half dude
you're complaining about seven people in
front of you well you know yeah i mean
did you duck walk i hadn't planned no i
didn't i experienced no physical
discomfort okay there you go see uh but
when i get up to the uh register
the guy is like
silence there's a there's silence and
there's
there's big eyes okay i'm like oh no
because there's now there's seven people
behind me everybody is in a holiday mood
which is not a good thing usually when
you're mailing things
and then he's like
rhett
i'm like yep
that's like now yeah and i'm like dude i
don't want to do this right now
and uh
he's he's a big fan
uh and i appreciate that
and he ends up
so we have our
this okay listen i'm not trying to sound
like a douchebag
uh which it just happens which
which may
but
sometimes i have experienced this
multiple times that when somebody who is
doing a service for you whether they're
giving you food like a waiter
or they're checking you out of a store
or they're
shipping something off for you
if they're very excited
if they're a fan and they're very
excited that's
99 of their brain is focused on that and
now they're one percent is focused on
the job that they're doing for you which
in this case actually this was very
important that these two checks that i
was sending oh yeah got to the right
places at the right time okay
and uh i'm like dude don't because you
could tell it i can't figure out a part
i can't tell you how many times my order
has gotten screwed up but so many things
have gotten screwed up because
i appreciate people being fans i'm a
huge fan of fans okay i love fans and i
love that people are fans you're doing
great but
when they're doing something for me and
they screw it up because they're a fan
it's just it's a little it's frustrating
right and so but most of the time it's
just like oh you gave me meatloaf and i
ordered you know
fish
i can eat that it's fine but uh
this was like if you screw this up it's
gonna it's gonna mess my life up a
little bit right now okay in a way that
i don't want it to be messed up so
he he's doing his thing and and then
he's
talking to me he's kind of giving me his
his resume
you know you got any open positions oh
okay going into that giving me the
resume
uh and i'm kind of explaining the pro
like i don't really that's not i don't
do you know i don't accept applications
that's not how it works anymore
but here's what if you're interested
there's postings and i'm like trying to
be helpful right and uh
and then he's like okay well can i get a
picture i'm like sure man of course i'm
being nice not being an [ __ ] i'm
think i'm not i'm thinking about all the
people behind me who are impatiently
waiting
patiently waiting maybe they were
impatient
and then he's like can i get a picture
i'm like sure man he's like he pulls out
his phone and he just again from over
the counter he's going to just take a
picture of me
and i'm like dude you got to be in the
picture
he's like well first let me get one of
just you i was like i'm just getting a
picture man
he's like
at this point you do not have the job
that didn't exist that you're trying to
apply and then he's like uh
no just let me get one real quick and
i'm just like okay oh he's arguing yeah
and then he's like
and then i'm like okay and i just kind
of stand there and look at the camera
and of course i got my mask on this is
not gonna be a great picture
um
and he's like
hey then he's like you're gonna you're
gonna do something
oh no
you're gonna
like give the peace sign or something he
said give the people i don't know what
he said but i was like i didn't respond
at that point i was embarrassed
because i'm like these people they don't
know who i am and they're all in the
picture by the way yo they're all in the
background
i'd love to see that picture
and then i'm like but come on out here
and let's get a picture so he came
around and the other employee leaves the
other register which had somebody at it
to take our picture
and then there was something happening
with the register and he had to go to
the other register
and then and then and then at that point
the other employee the other teen
employee
is picking up on the fact that
errors may be about to be made
you can tell he's sensing it and he was
like did you make sure that you put that
check in that envelope and that check in
that envelope because we had to move to
this register
and that's the only thing i'm thinking
it's like yeah exactly make sure the
check is in that envelope in that
envelope i think it got there i think
you figured it out but uh
that wasn't one of my favorite
interactions
again i i appreciate i appreciate the
enthusiasm
uh i get nervous in in the lines because
i mean it's nice to i like it when i see
people who recognize me
like there's that there's like a shutter
it's like hey it feels i mean it's kind
of you know it's kind of cool you get to
a lot of people don't get to experience
that moment of like
seeing somebody see you and they kind of
have this like physical
response yeah and then the line keeps
moving so they can't do anything about
it so they're like
it's like they're just kind of standing
there shell shocked because it's the
only way when somebody meets you
that you have permission to just walk
away without saying anything so i kind
of enjoy that when being in line but
then you see them
500 times after that yeah so you did so
they do have the opportunity to get the
stuff together so they can like
say hello yeah and again i i don't think
there's i don't think it's possible to
talk about this without seeming like a
douchebag
because it's not a very relatable
experience to be
to get recognized so i i acknowledge
that it's just and i and i do appreciate
i do appreciate it and i don't mind
people approaching but it's just like
there are certain circumstances
in which
it's especially inconvenient especially
for other people who are right trying to
get something done
and those in those circumstances
um
again i was nice i didn't and then i
didn't i almost apologized to the line
of people as i left but i was just like
i'm just gonna leave yeah just get out
of there i'll just leave just get out of
there
disneyland that that that was great um
it was great for lily to be home and for
us to do something as a family because
she had a number of people to see
um you know to reconnect with her
friends and stuff like that for the
handful of days that she was back home
so it gave us our dedicated time because
then once we got back we did the
thanksgiving
lunch but then after that she was kind
of gone
um seeing other people which we totally
expected and understood and then
she's back off at college but only just
for a couple of weeks before the the
christmas break so it was a it was a
great experience being reconnected
especially because like we all got along
because we were in the happiest place on
earth and i wasn't in charge
i think that really worked
so um yeah uh it was a success last
thing i'll share is that um
[Music]
usually the day after thanksgiving we go
and get a christmas tree uh-huh we
didn't because the family was hanging on
by thread
you know dropping like flies and i'm
just trying not to get sick so
uh jesse was in no
mood to go get a tree and we had
decorated a little bit before everybody
got there with like
there's multiple trees there's multiple
trees you know there's like there's a
tree we i don't there's already there's
like four christmas trees in our house
but not
and they're small like kids have little
ones and i'm not talking big so you're
not gonna do a real one this year well
but so jesse's like we got to go get the
real tree
and i'm like doing the math on this and
thinking
so
we're going to put this tree up and you
know then we're going back home to north
carolina
like mid-december yeah and then we're
not going to be back until after the new
year
and it's like who we're not going to
have anybody else over and it's i i just
start realizing how much of a scrooge i
am when it comes to the decorations
because i'm like the decorations just
feel like
they're
they're they're for us by us
you know what i'm saying and so it's
like
the bios part is the part that i have
trouble with because i'm like ah we're
gonna have to get this thing if it's
just for you we have to do the lights
and and she and but she's like but for
the kiss it's like last christmas year
i'm like well there's lots of christmas
decorations there's multiple trees he's
got one in his room
we haven't yet gotten the treat i almost
talked her into but there are other
trees in other places but just not you
don't have a man we don't have the main
real tree that we put it sounds like my
dad man they've got so i mean halloween
they decorated for christmas they got
like eight trees
it's like they live for it i'm trying to
we got one tree jesse loves it i
appreciate the listen again i
experienced the benefit because i didn't
help with that all i did was went into
the attic and
like pushed my back was already messed
up so i was pushing the boxes to the
entrance and then lock was taking them
down
uh
and then jesse's taking this stuff out
but
i don't know i think we may have passed
the point of no return for having a tree
and then i and then i'm like but if we
do get one let's get a fake pre-lit
treat and listen i know the argument's
against it that's what we have now
that's what we got last year and so
here's my question i love it you take it
out and you how hard is it to
put together easy three sections
and it's there and then it falls down
and then that's it and then you're like
this is disappointing and every and like
then you start hearing the complaints
it's not a real it's too short it's not
this it's not that and then it's like
but just decorate it and once you
decorate it it's fine just fine you know
because all that happens is
is the tree basically because we do all
the stuff to take care of but then it
basically dies before we leave yeah it
starts it stops taking water and then we
get back and it's dead
and then we take all and just taking the
stuff off of the tree
it causes all the little needles to go
everywhere and then we got to take it
out and put it down next to the you
nearly kill whoever you're trying to do
this with trying to get it to the curb
are there yeah i'm with you man i but i
know i'm like are there pre-decorated
trees you got pre-lit
it's like can you go all the way
pre-decorate it
you know just pull it out of the box
he's not gonna go for that you know it's
just like
it's all done but
i will say the only thing that i usually
help with
is the lights
which is the worst part and
the top of the tree yeah and so you'll
see why i if the lights are pre-lit i
don't worry about that all i'm i'll put
the three sections together are your
other trees not pre-lit
you don't know because you didn't do
those i don't they're all fake okay they
better be pre-lit you don't want to i
don't think they're pre-lit
we're not in the 90s anymore okay
wake up so anyway i kind of i love
christmas i love the holidays i like the
decorations yeah but i'm just i'm a
little bit of a scrooge when i'm like
who why are we doing this we're not
we're if we were going to be here
through christmas and the whole time we
had a bunch of people coming over right
that's not happening
so
am i a scrooge hashtag your biscuits
yeah i might give a wreck
um
i've been really looking forward to
the uh
peter jackson directed beatles
docu-series which takes it's called get
back
and um
i always think that it's on
apple but it's on disney plus
yeah because i looked forever i looked
all over apple and i couldn't find it
looking they're wrong disney plus i will
say
i've only watched
like an hour and a half of it
which is not much more than half of the
first of the three
six hours total or something yeah it's
like he really peter
it so it's um
the footage
leading up to
their
their last performance
but they didn't know that
at the time of course
it was just their first performance in
more than two years that they were going
to develop new material for
to to perform
for us for a tv special what it would be
and then they had a documentary crew
which that's what this footage is from
it's like film documentary and then the
release of the album which um
became the let it be album
if i'm correct i believe i am so
uh
we heard some good stuff about it we
actually went to a restaurant and they
said how's your how was your
thanksgiving and the waiter said um it
was great i watched the the beatles docu
series and i loved it that's apparently
all they did and i was like oh it's out
and i was so excited everyone was
talking about it on twitter about how
amazing it was
it's it's a test
of of patience and a fandom so i'm
giving this recommendation couch and
it's not for
it's not for everybody because it's just
a but it if you're really into it it's
an amazing experience but don't watch it
when you're sleepy because it's a fly on
the wall
um
just footage of them trying to pull
together
physically like be in the same space
again and start to write songs they're
bringing material together and they're
starting to play and
there's these
i i get goosebumps talking about the
just the
flashes of creativity where you see paul
mccartney showing up
and george and ringo in there john's not
even there yet and then he starts he's
just he starts writing get back
no no
you know he's like
it's the genesis of that song
was fully documented
in that environment under all of this
pressure and you see all of their
personalities and their interactions and
i get the impression that there's not
footage like this of them that exists
because people because everybody's
talking about like
like i saw marc maron tweet
they're they're they're the guys i
always thought they would be but like
and he's a huge fan yeah it's like
there's just no one has seen but i've
never hung out with him like this liked
uh yeah and people are talking about and
now i i've only watched half of the
first one and then
there's some things that really start to
happen
you know like uh
i know that george leaves he quits
the band
in the midst of this so it gets really
good but it's like you really have to be
committed to it
um and you have to be attentive to the
points where
the magic of those moments
is really set up by kind of like the fly
on the wall
20 minutes of them just
interacting
so it's it's
at first i like had tears in my eyes and
then i got bored
so it's it's uh it's a little bit of
both
but if you push through there's these
there's these moments that are just
captured i mean based on what i've
already seen
that are probably extraordinary and it
does go it does go somewhere it's just
maybe i'm in the most boring part of it
but i'm still recommending it get back
all right speaking of that we will get
back with you uh next week
um we're going to talk about our
purchases
of from 2021 that we did we think same
thing we did last year going through i'm
going through all my amazon i think link
is expanding outside of that but we're
going through everything that we
purchased they're going to be less stuff
than you the highlights of the things
that we bought
in 2021. all right talk at you next week
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]